[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going my brows my name is Peter
Pan
welcome to I only I am no I dare to say
that I think it means purple troll and
whatever language this was suggested to
me long ago but anyway what is the main
character's name his name is penis can't
write so I'm just gonna look good are
there's something we are our name is
something okay we heard a rumor about a
mansion on the outskirts of town
they say there's Marshall I live sure
yeah let's go there because there's a
monster living there alright it's a lot
it's a lot prettier on the inside and
the two of me already call it here hey
let's get out of here
what's wrong with checking you are you
scared okay I'm gonna mess up the wait
isn't that impossible
hey yeah be careful stupid oh you so
stupid oh I broke this blade no it's
just a stupid blade it's do these are
scared of a blade blade is shattered on
the client
I found the I didn't bleach ow okay I'm
gonna show these guys they're gonna be
like oh we are so stupid
we were scalper hey where did you go
all right guys
maybe they went over here Oh what was
that I don't know if I want to go there
it won't happen
yeah I won't do it either
okay whatever I will go up air let's see
where are those stupid are maybe this
beautiful painted map beautiful very no
I'd wonder it's locked
this however works okay what do we what
was that okay
shivering she Yammer egg wash every ah
you stupid son-of-a-bitch
are you [ __ ] ever egg hi [ __ ] hate
you
what are the others okay let's check
these no I'm the daughter still locked
is this not okay no it still it won't
open
sad face okay heart is locked
what about these don't open either oh
jeez
I don't even know anymore let's go down
okay here maybe it won't open either
this is a problem
really right uh-huh okay so where do I
go then maybe exit I can't ah man let me
travel I mean big trouble gosh maybe
here not that ours line wait
we know I picked up that thing maybe
click more stuff microwave no sink know
about down here oh you can walk here
holy [ __ ] said them cannot can't this
[ __ ] this game room I second tibia we're
like Pokemon or something I don't even
know nice no ok it's got to be something
with that friggin [ __ ] what are you on
for me stop shivering chambray oh god I
hate you
ah what is this I found the eyes I'm not
wacky skull you okay let's go to library
whatever that is yeah that's not there
not here
that's not here well whatever you're
probably downstairs who keeps the
library on the second floor well I guess
a lot of people keeps lying around check
funny um would guess yes yes yep what
this house that and out laughs oh [ __ ]
four controls man we get what you got
let's go alright let me just read this
what is this
I finally had a bedroom key no the
gloves come on oh man game over
no way what's this a maken wait it stars
over no no no I can't start over nah nah
okay fine
sorry bro I really don't have that much
time today whoa wait star II hope you
can see me in this
Oh whatever you probably couldn't anyway
hope you enjoyed like affairs and all
that kind of stuff for now see you
tomorrow
[Music]
nah